so
good afternoon we have just finished an
extraordinary
summit
of nato leaders to address the biggest
threat to our security in a generation
president putin's war against ukraine
the people of ukraine are assisting with
courage and determination
fighting for the freedom and for their
future
we stand with them
presidency addressed us with an
impassioned message
thanking nato allies for the significant
support we are providing
and stressing the vital importance of
even more military assistance
today
natoli disagreed that we must
and will provide further
support to ukraine
we will continue to impose unprecedented
costs on russia
and we will reinforce
allied deterrence and defense
leaders approved
our four new battle groups in bulgaria
hungary romania and slovakia
these are in addition to the four
already in the baltic countries and
poland
so we have eight uh multinational
nato battle groups
now from the
baltic sea to the black sea
across europe there are 100 000 u.s
troops
[Music]
supporting nato efforts
and european allies and canada have also
stepped up
we have forty thousand forces under
direct nato command
mostly in the eastern part of the
alliance
backed by
major air enabled power
including an unprecedented five carrier
strike groups
from the high north to the mediterranean
today nato leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defence for the longer term
to face a new security reality
on land
we will have substantially more forces
in the eastern part of the lawrence
at higher readiness
with more pre-positioned equipment and
supplies
in the air
we will deploy more jets and strengthen
our integrated air and missile defense
at sea
we will have a
carrier strike groups submarines
and significant numbers of combat ships
on a persistent basis
we will also strengthen our cyber
defenses
and enhance our exercises
focusing on collective defense
and interoperability
i expect we will decide on the details
at our next summit in madrid in june
today allah leaders also agreed to
provide further support to ukraine
helping to uphold their fundamental
right to self-defense
allies are also equipping ukraine with
significant military supplies
including anti-tank and air defense
systems and drones
which are proving highly effective
as well as substantial financial and
humanitarian aid
today we agreed to do more
including cyber security assistance
and equipment to help ukraine protect
against biological chemical radiological
and nuclear threats
this could include detection
protection and medical supplies
as well as
training for the community contamination
and crisis management
we are determined to do
all we can to support ukraine
and i welcome the concrete offers
of assistance made by allies today
at the same time we have a
responsibility to ensure the conflict
does not escalate further
because this would
be even more dangerous
and more devastating
allies agreed that we must also increase
our support for other partners at risk
from uh russia um and
from
at risk from russian threats and
interference including georgia and
bosnia and herzegovina
working together and with
the european union we must help them
uphold their sovereignty and strengthen
their resilience
we also addressed beijing's role in the
crisis
today allied leaders called on china to
refrain from supporting russia's war
effort
china must not provide economic or
military support
for the russian invasion instead beijing
should use its significant influence on
russia
and promote
an
immediate peaceful resolution
allies also agree that belarus must stop
acting as an accomplice to putin's
invasion
at today's meeting leaders reaffirmed
strong our strong commitment to nato's
open door policy under article 10 of the
washington treaty
nato enlargement has been an historic
success
spreading democracy freedom and
prosperity across europe
one month
since the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine
nato security environment has
fundamentally changed for the long haul
and we are responding
but security but security does not come
for free
and doing war will cost more
so nato leaders agreed to read double
efforts
to meet the defence investment pledge we
made in 2014.
allies will submit additional plans on
how to meet the pledge in time for the
madrid summit in june
and i welcome that a number of allies
today announced plans for significant
increases
in defence spending
at this dangerous time transatlantic
unity and salati
are vital europe and north america are
standing and will continue to stand
strong together in nato and that i'm
going to take your questions
okay cnn
mr secretary general thank you um
president zelinski in his address to
nato
accused russia of deploying phosphorus
munitions i'm wondering whether nato has
seen evidence of that and what your
response is or would be
and then i'm wondering did you discuss
during this meeting a permanent basing
of forces in any of these countries such
as the baltics
and abandoning the nato-russia founding
act
so we are resetting nato's returns and
defense for the long term
uh with more troops with more air assets
and more maritime capabilities
we have already increased our presence
in the east and today we decided on four
new battle groups and the leaders
agreed to task our military commanders
to provide options
uh for a long-term reset of our
presence our military posture in the
eastern part of the alliance and across
the whole alliance
details will be then decided at our
summit in june but that comes on top of
what we have already done so this is
long term we are prepared for long haul
because uh
we can all today say
that
uh that
the russia invasion president putin's
invasion of ukraine
has changed our security
environment
for the long term it's a new reality
it's uh it's uh it's a new normal and
nato is responding for the long term
we have seen
very credible reports about
the use of
also the use of military force against
civilians
and of course this is a great concern uh
for all nato allies
nbc
secretary general thank you for taking
my question how do you believe nato will
respond if china begins to support
russia economically and perhaps with
military supplies and also do you
believe that there's a role to play um
for nato when it comes to alleviating
energy costs and i'm talking about
speaking directly to saudi arabia and
other opec producers thank you
nato allies are coordinating their
efforts when it comes to also energy
security and it was also addressed in a
meeting today
to
step up supplies to diversify
uh
sources of supply and uh
and also also to reduce dependence on
supplies from from russia
uh and uh and later on today i also
participate in the g7 meeting and of
course in different frameworks g7
working with the eu uh
there are different formats where nato
allies
address the need
to strengthen energy security and reduce
dependence on
on on russian oil and
gas
our message to china is that they should
join the rest of the world and clearly
condemn
the brutal war against
ukraine
and not support
russia
neither with
with economic support or of course not
with military support okay we'll go to
interface ukraine late in the second row
general news agency interface ukraine i
would like to ask you if polish
leadership put at the table today for
discussion the proposal to send
peacekeeping mission to ukraine and if
yes what kind of discussion it was and
is there is some conclusion thank you
as we discussed a wide range of uh uh
issues uh and
uh and the message is that we have to
stand united uh and also that we need to
provide support to ukraine but at the
same time we have a responsibility
to ensure that this conflict do not
become a full-fledged war
between nato and russia
and
and that's also reason why allies have
may declare that we will not deploy
troops on the ground
in
in ukraine
because
the only
way to do that is to be prepared to
engage in full
conflict with
russian troops
financial times
thank you very much secretary general
congratulations on your uh annual
extension um you said in the statement
that allies agreed to enhance
preparedness and readiness for chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats is that based on credible
intelligence that those threats could be
imminent and how does the alliance
strengthen its protection against those
threats thank you
so we are concerned
partly because we see the rhetoric
and we see that russia is trying to
create some kind of pretext accusing
ukraine united states nato allies for
preparing to use
chemical and biological weapons and we
have seen before that this uh uh
way of accusing others is actually a way
to try to create a pretext who do the
same uh themselves
uh and and of course accusations against
ukraine and nato allies are absolutely
false
any use of chemical
weapons will
totally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international
law
and
it will have
wide spread consequences
and of course be extremely dangerous
it will
affect the people in ukraine but there's
also a risk that will have a direct
effect on people living in nato
countries because
we can see contamination we can see the
spread of
um chemical agents or
biological weapons into our countries
um
we also know that russia has used
chemical agents against its own
opposition and they have used it on nato
territory in salisbury before and we
also know that russia has facilitated
supported
the assad regime in syria
when they used chemical weapons against
their own population
so this just highlights the importance
of uh ending this war immediately
because this is a dangerous situation
and therefore we impose the sanctions so
we if we support uh ukraine
um
allies agreed to supply equipment to
help ukraine protect against chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats
this could include
detection
equipment protection and medical support
as well as training
for the
contamination and crisis management
we are also enhancing allies
preparedness and readiness for chemical
and biological and nuclear threats
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
defense elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new backing groups so we are taking
measures both to support ukraine and
also to defend ourselves they will go to
al jazeera
secretary general james bayes from al
jazeera president zielenski when he
addressed you recall the fact he first
spoke to you a month ago and he says he
didn't get clear answers
so this time he asked you specifically
for one percent of all your tanks for
one percent of all your aircraft for
multi-launch rocket systems anti-ship
weapons and means of air defense a very
specific list what is your clear answer
we all listened very carefully to
president zerensky and many of the
leaders in the room uh have had contacts
with him over these weeks i also spoke
with him and
under the ukrainian defenseman
participated in our defense ministerial
meeting last week we listened carefully
and of course we took note of his very
compassionate message to all nato allies
nato allies provide significant support
to ukraine
and we provide also legal weapons
advanced systems and also systems that
help them to
shoot down planes
and
attack
battle tanks with anti-tank weapons and
many other types of
of systems including drones i will not
go into the details of the exact type of
systems we are deploying this close
contact between nato allies and ukraine
but what i can say is that allies do
what they can
to support ukraine with weapons so
ukraine can defend themselves
self-defense is a right to enshrine the
new and charter
at the same time we have a
responsibility
to
prevent this conflict from becoming a
full-fledged war in europe involving not
only ukraine and russia but
nato allies and russia that will be more
dangerous and more devastating and uh
and i think we have to be honest about
that and that's exactly what we have
been in our meeting today and also what
i say to you
in the press conference now
well what we do is that we are
delivering a lot of
equipment and that is an answer but i
will not go into the the details i don't
think that's the wise for operational
reasons if i listed exactly what and
when and how
we are delivering uh essential equipment
to ukraine nato allies have stepped up
and it's essential for the progress they
have been able to make in the fight
against
the invading russian forces thank you
very much colleagues i know there are
many questions i'm afraid the secretary
general needs to go to the g7 meeting
but there will be other briefings
throughout the day thank you so much